This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。百分之二百的保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和增强恢复力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你有这个能力，你就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean. mean for our psychology. Hello everybody and welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一档我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。
New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I hope you've all been well that something, I don't know, special or joyous has happened in your life recently and that you are prepared and ready to get into this particularly philosophical episode. or topic today. We're talking about success, specifically of course, success in our 20s and whether it's time for us as a generation, as a society, to rethink what it truly means to be a successful individual and why it might be time to move past some of the traditional and limiting ways of thinking about achievement and accolades and to an extent happiness.
新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析20多岁时的心理学。我希望你们最近都过得很好，生活中发生了一些特别的、快乐的事情，并且你们已经准备好探讨这个特别具哲学性的节目或话题了。我们今天讨论的是成功，特别是我们在20多岁时的成功，以及作为我们这一代人、作为整个社会，是否是时候重新思考“成功的人”到底意味着什么，为什么现在可能是时候抛弃一些关于成就和荣誉的传统且局限的思维方式，并在某种程度上抛弃对幸福的狭隘理解。
How can we truly be successful in our 20s without getting bogged down in comparison, what others think of us, doing it for other people, feeling like we have something to prove what is actually truly worthwhile to pursue and to care about in this decade? This has been one of my brain's favorite go-to topics to overthink about in the last few weeks, last few months as well, because quite frankly, I've been feeling very overwhelmed as someone still in my 20s by the direction of my career. And by the direction of my career, I mean to a large extent this podcast. And I'm going to break the fourth wall for a second and just say, you know,
我们在20多岁时如何才能真正取得成功，而不陷入攀比、别人对我们的看法、为了别人而活、觉得自己有什么需要证明的东西的泥潭中？在这个十年里，什么才是真正值得追求和关心的？在过去的几周、过去的几个月里，这也是我大脑最喜欢过度思考的话题之一，因为坦率地说，作为一个仍然处在20多岁的人，我对自己的职业发展方向感到非常压抑。而说到职业发展方向，在很大程度上是指这个播客。我要打破第四堵墙一下，只想说，你知道，
I absolutely love doing the show. It is so purposeful to me. It aligns with who I am. It aligns with what I believe deeply about the human spirit and about the power of psychology and the power of information to heal. But I do miss the time in my life when I was only doing it out of pure passion and love. The podcast is now my full-time job. And so there are a lot of additional elements to think about, you know, how do I make money from this? Am I getting enough listens? And biggest of all, how can I be successful? And what does that success mean? Does it mean publicity? Does it mean recognition or does it actually mean having real impact and zooming out a little bit, touching some grass, having a bit of perspective and actually just separating myself from
我非常热爱做这个节目。它对我有很强的目的性。它符合我是谁。它符合我内心深处对人类精神、心理学力量以及信息治愈力量的信仰。但我确实怀念我生活中只出于纯粹的热情和爱去做这件事的时光。这个播客现在是我的全职工作。所以有许多额外的因素需要考虑，你知道，我如何从中赚钱？我的收听量够吗？最重要的是，我怎样才能成功？这种成功意味着什么？是知名度吗？是认可吗？还是说它实际上意味着产生真正的社会影响力，稍微退一步，回归现实，拥有一点人生视角，并真正将自己从
my job and being a happy person. Is that what actually makes you a successful individual? Having a deep and meaningful connection to what you're doing, yes, but also a connection to who you are, what you actually enjoy in life and who you are beyond your career. beyond your work, beyond what other people may be seeing. I think I've been focusing on the wrong things and it's rubbed me of a little bit of joy. And, you know, as a group, as 20-somethings, we are, have become very consumed with being impressive and is that constant pursuit of success actually making us less happy and less
我的工作中剥离出来，成为一个快乐的人。这才是真正让你成为一个成功之人的原因吗？对你所做的事情有深厚而有意义的联系，是的，但也要与你是谁、你在生活中真正享受什么以及超越你的职业、超越你的工作、超越其他人可能看到的自己保持联系。我想我一直专注于错误的事情，这剥夺了我的一点快乐。而且，你知道，作为一个群体，作为二十几岁的人，我们已经变得非常痴迷于给人留下深刻印象，而这种对成功的不断追求，是否真的让我们作为一个世代变得不那么快乐、不那么
centered as a generation because we are too fixated on what our life looks like versus what our life contains. As you can probably tell, there has been a real mental tug of war for me. And last weekend I booked this beautiful Airbnb in the mountains just to get away, did some soul searching, did some digging, and came to some conclusions about what it means to, I don't know, have the achievements, have the accolades, be happy with your life, perhaps beyond the frills and the excess of what we think success looks like. So I'm very excited for this episode. if you like more about chatty, deep thinker-style topics that veer into more of the extensional, philosophical conversations, obviously still with a healthy dose of psychology, you are going to love this topic.
从容，因为我们太执着于我们的生活看起来是什么样的，而不是我们的生活包含什么。正如你大概能看出的那样，我内心一直在进行一场真正的心理拔河。上周末，我在山里预订了一间美丽的Airbnb民宿，只是为了逃离现实，进行了一些深刻的自我反省，并得出了一些结论，关于拥有成就、拥有荣誉、对生活感到满意意味着什么，也许这超越了我们认为成功所具有的花哨外表和过剩物质。所以我对这期节目感到非常兴奋。如果你喜欢更多偏向闲聊、深度思考风格的话题，这些话题会延伸到更多存在主义、哲学方面的对话，当然仍然包含健康的心理学知识，你会爱上这个话题的。
So without further ado, let's get into how we can be truly successful in our 20s and what success actually means at its core. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
废话不多说，让我们探讨如何在20多岁时真正获得成功，以及成功在其核心究竟意味着什么。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和增强恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of, of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.0 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
我们对世界感到恐慌的许多问题，实际上都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2.0”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小肯（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and
谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及
conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。但我们仍在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两码事，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这是一场长达数年的法庭之争，旨在证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到
what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is
他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是
Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《The Girlfriend》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Being successful feels really important for a lot of us during this decade. It's definitely up there, I think, with some of our bigger anxieties about the future. You know, how do I set up my life during this chapter? to be impressive and to be secure later on. I think our fixation on this obviously comes from a place of wanting certainty, right? If I'm successful in my journeys, I'll probably be successful in my 30s and beyond,
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在这个十年里，取得成功对我们许多人来说感觉非常重要。我认为，它绝对名列我们对未来的重大焦虑之中。你知道，我如何在这一人生阶段规划我的生活，以便在未来给人留下深刻印象并获得安全感。我认为我们对此的执着显然源于对确定性的渴望，对吧？如果我在旅程中取得成功，我可能在30多岁及以后也会成功，
which means I won't have to worry about money. I won't have to worry about having something to do. I won't have to worry about feeling behind. So that self-preservation is one element of it. But I also think that our, you know, excessive fascination and fixation with success, also comes from a place of ego, wanting to feel important in the world. And that sense of importance is impacted by what society tells us is valuable and what makes someone, again, an important person, someone to look to someone to feel proud of or maybe
这意味着我不用担心金钱。我不用担心无事可做。我不用担心会有落后于人的感觉。所以这种自我保护是其中的一个元素。但我也认为，我们对成功的过度迷恋和执着，也源于一种自负，想要在世界上感到重要。而这种重要感受到社会告诉我们的什么是宝贵的，以及是什么让一个人——再次强调——成为一个重要的人、一个受敬仰的人、一个让人感到骄傲的人、或者某种程度上甚至
even envious of in a sense. Spoiler alert, the people who we typically see as successful, you know, it's normally not that they are a kind person or that they have a lot of good memories. It's not that they are led by purpose or that they're acting small or that they're just a nice, happy person. It's typically a lot more materialistic and grander than that. What makes someone important and therefore successful comes down to being the best at something, having a lot of money, getting a lot of attention or recognition, having something to your name. I'm going to ask you to picture a successful person for a second. I'm guessing your mind probably when you're going to to someone like Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos or a celebrity like Taylor Swift or Beyonce,
让人嫉妒的人的影响。剧透一下，我们通常认为成功的人，你知道，通常并不是因为他们是一个善良的人或者有很多美好的回忆。并不是因为他们有目标感、表现得低调、或者他们只是一个善良、快乐的人。这通常要比这更加物质化、更加宏大。是什么让一个人变得重要并因此而成功，归根结底在于成为某领域的佼佼者、拥有大量金钱、获得大量的关注或认可、名下拥有资产。请让我请你想象一个成功的人一会儿。我猜当你想的时候，你的脑海里可能会浮现出埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）或杰夫·贝佐斯（Jeff Bezos）这样的人，或者泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）或碧昂丝（Beyonce）这样的名人，
that is not an accident. The image of success that we have is, again, very limited, very exaggerated, but also very individualistic and closely aligned with fame. You know, what can you achieve? What have you done? What level of attention do you receive for your hard work? What kind of money have you made? Maybe this also comes down to celebrity worship as well.
这不是偶然的。我们拥有的成功形象，再次强调，是非常有限的、非常夸张的，但也是非常个人主义的，并且与名气紧密相连。你知道，你能取得什么成就？你做过什么？你的辛勤工作获得了什么级别的关注？你赚了多少钱？也许这也归结为对名人的崇拜。
If you want an amazing podcast specifically on this topic, you need to listen to Amanda Montel's podcast, Magical Overthinkers, where she talks about this and she talks about how our collective obsession with celebrities and the parasocial relationship that we have with them has collectively made us feel more compelled or attracted by the idea of fame and perhaps less satisfied with an ordinary. life. And you want to know something fascinating. A study run in 2022 showed that people who are more drawn into celebrity worship often do report feeling less satisfied with what they've accomplished. And they do also believe that they would be happier if they were more like the celebrities that they see or that they were famous. So again, our perception of what makes someone successful is very exclusive and very narrow and very much reserved for the best of the best, something that, you know, unfortunately we can't all be. I think this is also elevated by our, you know, this new wave, I guess,
如果你想要一个专门针对这个话题的精彩播客，你需要听听阿曼达·蒙泰尔（Amanda Montel）的播客《Magical Overthinkers》，她在其中谈到了这一点，并谈到了我们对名人的集体痴迷以及我们与他们之间的准社会关系如何集体让我们感到更受名气概念的吸引或诱惑，而对平凡的生活感到不那么满意。你想知道一件迷人的事吗。2022年的一项研究表明，那些更容易沉迷于名人崇拜的人确实报告说，对自己所取得的成就感到不那么满意。他们也确实相信，如果他们更像他们所看到的那些名人或者他们自己成名了，他们会更快乐。所以，我们对什么让人成功的看法是非常排他的、非常狭隘的、并且很大程度上只留给最优秀的人——这是一种你知道不幸的是我们并非所有人都能成为的东西。我认为这也被我们的，你知道，这股新浪潮所提升了，我猜，
of online success and media success and social media success, where anyone can become recognizable or popular by posting from their bedroom. And so this idea that we could all be notable, that we could all be popular, that we could all have this kind of online, huge life is a lot more available to us. And a lot of us are leaning into that self-promotion. Even if you are kind of detached from social media and how social media hype is really feeding into our, you know, obsession with success, if you're in the corporate world, right? just you're like equivalent of LinkedIn. There is a cultural shift even on that platform towards self-promotion. Like what are my successes?
即网络成功、媒体成功和社交媒体成功，在这里，任何人都可以通过在卧室发帖而变得引人注目或受欢迎。因此，这种我们都可以引人注目、我们都可以受欢迎、我们都可以拥有这种网络宏大生活观念，离我们更近了。我们中的许多人都倾向于这种自我宣传。即使你有点脱离社交媒体以及社交媒体的炒作是如何真正助长我们对成功的痴迷的，如果你身处企业界，对吧？就相当于职场社交平台LinkedIn。甚至在这个平台上，文化也在向自我宣传转变。比如我的成功是什么？
What is my worth if someone else cannot see it? If someone else cannot judge me by it. If someone else is not impressed, we're looking externally for that confirmation, then what we're doing is correct, that we're enough, that we're pushing ourselves enough. rather than trusting our compass for A, what we actually care about,
如果别人看不到我的价值，我的价值是什么。如果别人无法以此来评判我。如果别人没有留下深刻印象，我们在向外部寻求这种确认，确认我们做的事情是正确的、我们已经足够好了、我们对自己的推动够了，
B, what we actually want to be doing and see whether we're enjoying ourselves. When success becomes so individually focused, it really does put a lot of pressure on us to be working harder and to be elevating ourselves in comparison to others because success starts to feel very competitive, very glamorous, rather than collaborative and simple. It's not about how happy you are. It's not about what you do for your community.
而不是信任我们自己的指南针，去判断A，我们真正关心的是什么，B，我们实际上想做什么，并看看我们是否在享受其中。当成功变得如此注重个人时，它确实给我们带来了巨大的压力，迫使我们更加努力工作，并在与他人的比较中提升自己，因为成功开始让人感觉非常具有竞争性、非常迷人，而不是合作性的和简单的。这不关乎你有多快乐。这不关乎你为社区做了什么。
It's not about how you give back and what the world needs, but how do you make yourself feel impressive in this space? And let me just say, this is not a criticism. I definitely buy into this all the time that success equals self-promotion and success equals image. But I also think that that is contributing to a lot of mental and emotional consequences for this group of people. age group. Firstly, when we're not meeting the criteria for a conventionally successful life,
这不关乎你如何回馈社会以及世界需要什么，而是关乎你如何让自己在这个空间里显得令人印象深刻？请让我说，这不是批评。我绝对一直都在盲目接受这一点，即成功等于自我宣传，成功等于形象。但我也认为，这正在给这一特定年龄段的人群带来许多心理和情绪上的后果。首先，当我们没有达到传统成功生活的标准时，
or you don't feel like a successful 20-something, it really makes us feel quite behind and therefore like a failure because we've been taught not to value ourselves as a person, but to value yourself based on output and what you can produce and how talented or impressive you are. And a unique kind of anxiety follows on from that, right, known as milestone anxiety. We have a whole episode on this from a few years ago, but for a refresher, milestone anxiety is a relatively new concept within the psychology space where we tend to experience a certain dread, panic that A, we are not where we want to be in life, and B, we're not where others are in their lives.
或者你觉得自己不像一个成功的二十几岁年轻人时，这确实会让我们觉得自己大大落后，并因此觉得自己是个失败者，因为我们被教导不要把自己当作一个人来珍视，而是要根据产出、你能生产什么以及你有多才华横溢或令人印象深刻来珍视自己。随之而来的是一种独特的焦虑，对吧，被称为里程碑焦虑。几年前我们有一整集关于这个主题的节目，但为了温习一下，里程碑焦虑是心理学领域一个相对较新的概念，我们往往会经历一种特定的恐惧和恐慌，即A，我们没有达到我们在生活中的期望位置，B，我们没有达到其他人生活中的位置。
There was a poll done on this very subject actually earlier this year, and it asked around 2,000 adults in the UK whether they were where they wanted to be in life or, meeting what they saw as success milestones. Around 80% of them said no. And as a follow-up, they said that they felt a huge sense of pressure to be further ahead and achieving more than they had at this stage. If only 20% of people in their 20s or in early adulthood feel like they're at a point where they can say that they are proud and comfortable in what they've achieved, that they are, you know, a good person, an impressive person, maybe our notions of what for a successful life are incorrect because it should not be excluding that many people.
今年早些时候，实际上就这个主题进行过一次民意调查，它询问了英国约2000名成年人，他们是否达到了生活中的期望位置，或者达到了他们眼中的成功里程碑。大约80%的人回答说没有。作为跟进，他们表示，他们感到了巨大的压力，觉得自己应该比现在走得更远，取得更多成就。如果只有20%处于20多岁或成年早期的年轻人觉得他们达到了可以为自己所取得的成就感到自豪和舒适的地步，觉得他们是，你知道的，一个好人、一个令人印象深刻的人，也许我们对成功生活的观念是不正确的，因为它不应该将这么多人排除在外。
Nearly no one is feeling like they measure up, which is probably a good reminder that if you are also feeling that way, you're actually part of the majority. Our limited view of success, that individualistic, very glamorous, heightened, exaggerated, grand, public idea of success is not one that most people can achieve. but it leaves most people feeling miserable that they can't. Now, if you are someone who was an overachiever, a perfectionist, perhaps you grew up being labeled as a golden or a gifted child, a straight-a-student, you're probably going to be more influenced by the pressure to be successful in your 20s than most.
几乎没有人觉得达到了标准，这可能是一个很好的提醒，如果你也有这种感觉，你实际上属于大多数人。我们对成功的狭隘看法——那种个人主义的、非常迷人的、高度夸张的、宏大的、公众眼中的成功观念——并不是大多数人能够实现的。但它却让大多数人因为无法实现而感到痛苦。现在，如果你是一个好胜心强的人、一个完美主义者，也许你从小就被贴上“黄金小孩”或“天赋异禀的孩子”、全A学生的标签，你可能比大多数人更容易受到20多岁时要成功的压力的影响。
A large facet of your identity, if you do see yourself as one of those people, is most likely derived from performing above the standard. from being admired or praised for your hard work, being able to push yourself harder than anyone else. A lot of individuals who grew up as overachievers find that the only way they can now tell if they're doing something that is valuable or if they're even happy with what they're doing is through external reinforcement because our internal system for judging whether something is worthwhile, whether we actually care about something, is broken. And we are so used to being praised, recognized, told we're good, and that is the fuel,
如果你认为自己是这类人，你身份的一个很大方面很可能来自于表现得高于标准。来自于因你的辛勤工作而受到钦佩或赞扬，能够比任何人都更努力地推动自己。许多从小就是好胜心强的人发现，他们现在判断自己是否在做有价值的事情、甚至是否对自己正在做的事情感到快乐的唯一方法是通过外部强化，因为我们内部用来判断某事是否值得、我们是否真的关心某事的系统已经崩溃了。我们太习惯于受到赞扬、认可、被告知我们很棒，而这就是燃料，
that is the motivation to keep going with something. So when we no longer have that when we get into our mid, our late 20s, we've kind of exited like the education system, we're kind of more responsible for our daily lives and our daily work without having someone telling us what to do, praising what we do. It can actually lead to a very broken sense of self. I'm no longer the best. I am no longer good. I'm no longer achieving things within this, within a certain structure, the way that I always have. And that can mean that we start to doubt our career choices. We feel like because we're not getting immediate feedback on things that
这就是继续做某事的动力。所以，当我们进入中期、晚期20多岁时不再拥有这些时，我们基本上已经退出了教育体系，我们对自己的日常生活和日常工作承担了更多责任，却没有人在一旁告诉我们该做什么、赞扬我们所做的事情。这实际上会导致一种破碎的自我感。我不再是最好的了。我不再优秀了。我不再以某种结构内一直以来的方式取得成就了。这意味着我们开始怀疑自己的职业选择。我们觉得因为我们没有得到关于事情的即时反馈，
we're a failure, that we're not doing well. And we struggle to take self-motivated risks, you know, because whether you're starting a new business, maybe you are pursuing social media, putting everything into a passion project, there will be times when you just have to follow your gut and you have to just believe in your goals without anyone encouraging you. But when we have this huge fixation on success, but we also really crave external validation for everything that we're doing, we're not always going to get that. And so our extrinsic motivation system becomes broken. and we feel like if we're not constantly being told that, yep, that's good, yet, you're doing really, really well, what are we even doing? Who even are we without that praise? It's a sickness,
我们就是失败者，我们做得不好。我们很难承担自我驱动的风险，你知道的，因为无论你是开创一项新业务，还是追求社交媒体，把全部心血投入到一个充满激情的项目中，总会有一些时候，你必须听从自己的直觉，你必须相信自己的目标，而没有任何人在一旁鼓励你。但是，当我们对成功有着巨大的执着，却又非常渴望对我们所做的每一件事都获得外部验证时，我们并不总是能得到这些。于是我们的外在动机系统崩溃了。我们觉得如果没有人不断地告诉我们，“是的，这很好”，“是的，你真的、真的很棒”，我们到底在做什么？如果没有这种赞扬，我们到底是谁？这真是一种病态，
really. And as we get older, it can be hard to shake that productivity, success-driven instinct. Because again, that's what we relied upon for most of our lives to bring us confidence, bring us self-esteem, self-worth, and a purpose. So if you want some further reading on this, an article that I could not recommend enough. It was written by this publication called The School of Life, and it's titled The Secret Sorrow of Overevers. And it talks about how as overachievers, childhood overachievers, teenage overachievers age,
真的。随着我们年龄的增长，很难摆脱这种对生产力和成功的渴望驱动的本能。因为再次强调，这是我们生活中大部分时间所依赖的，用以带给我们自信、自尊、自我价值感和目标感。所以，如果你想对此做进一步阅读，有一篇文章我极力推荐。它由一个名为《The School of Life》（生活学校）的出版物撰写，标题是《The Secret Sorrow of Overachievers》（好胜者的秘密悲伤）。它谈到了随着好胜者、童年好胜者、青少年好胜者的年龄增长，
they find it very difficult to appreciate their wins in life. They talk about how our hunger for stereotypical success feeds the burnout cycle. It feeds our imposter syndrome. and of course the external validation dependency, but also, and this is crucial, it also creates an inability to ever enjoy the moments when we do feel like we've reached our goals. It's never enough. You know, the author kind of puts forward this proposition of like, and I don't even think
他们发现很难欣赏生活中的胜利。文章谈到我们对刻板成功的渴望如何助长了职业倦怠循环。它助长了我们的冒名顶替综合症，
this is just for overachievers, but can any of us taste success once and not get addicted? Is this not such something that we all crave to be seen? seen and acknowledged as being good. Let me introduce you to this concept called gold medal syndrome because when we talk about, you know, is success ever enough? This comes into it a lot. So obviously the Olympics has just finished and we've seen that, you know, a lot of people win gold medals, athletes who work their entire lives sometimes for less than 10 seconds.
当然还有对外部验证的依赖，而且——至关重要的是——这也导致我们永远无法享受当我们真正觉得实现了目标时的那些时刻。这永远不够。你知道，作者提出了这样一个观点，并且我认为这不仅仅适用于好胜者，难道我们当中有人能品尝一次成功而不上瘾吗？难道这不是我们所有人都渴望被看见、被认可为优秀之人的本能吗？让我向你介绍一个名为“金牌综合症”的概念，因为当我们谈论“成功是否永远足够”时，这经常涉及其中。很显然，奥运会刚刚结束，我们看到，你知道，许多人赢得金牌，运动员们有时为了不到10秒钟的比赛付出了毕生的努力。
And obviously losing is awful. It sucks. so you don't want to go to the Olympics and lose. But even for the people who win, they face this psychological phenomenon where upon getting everything that they ever wanted, upon being at the top of the podium, the literal top of the podium,
显然，失败是可怕的。这很糟糕，所以你不会想去参加奥运会却铩羽而归。但即使对于那些获胜的人来说，他们也面临着这样一种心理现象：在得到了他们想要的一切之后，在站在了领奖台的最顶端、字面意义上的领奖台最顶端时，
they are deeply, deeply unhappy. And what's actually happening here is something called the hedonic treadmill. We tend to think that success, that being the best, that being impressive, that being, you know, better than everyone else or doing something really, really cool that people think is really, really cool is going to make us really happy. And to an extent it does. But also, after we achieve
他们感到了深深的、深深的不快乐。而这里实际发生的事情被称为“享乐适应”（hedonic treadmill）。我们往往认为成功、成为最好的人、令人印象深刻、你知道的、比其他人更好或者做一些人们认为非常非常酷的酷事，会让我们非常快乐。在某种程度上确实如此。但是，在我们实现了
these huge things, these huge milestones, we tend to return to a pretty stable level of happiness. The myth that people get really hurt by is that being successful is somehow going to transform your life, transform your emotional state, and that you will never be miserable again. But actually a lot of successful people in the world are gravely unhappy. Many successful professionals struggle to enjoy their accomplishments because it becomes their entire life because they really elevate how it's going to feel to reach the finish line. And when they get there, it's actually quite miserable because they often neglect. a lot of other parts of their life, and they realized that being impressive and is really not
这些巨大的事情、这些巨大的里程碑之后，我们往往会回到一个相当稳定的幸福水平。让人深受其害的神话是，成功某种程度上会改变你的生活、改变你的情绪状态，并且你将再也不会痛苦。但实际上，世界上许多成功人士都极其不快乐。许多成功的专业人士很难享受他们的成就，因为这变成了他们生活的全部，因为他们过度提升了到达终点线时的感觉。而当他们到达那里时，情况其实相当悲惨，因为他们往往忽视了
what life is all about. There was a study done by UCLA a couple of years back, and it found that about 72% of successful entrepreneurs, 72% I want you to remember that number, they suffer from at least one mental health concern. A lot of them actually have increased rates of depression. You know, I think, I don't know what the number is now. I think it's one in three or maybe Maybe, yeah, one in three people will have some kind of mental health concern in their life. That's around 33%, 72%. 72% of people who are really in this like success, obsessive success driven world, feel that more intensely.
生活中的许多其他部分，并且他们意识到引人注目和成功真的不是生活的全部。几年前加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）做过一项研究，发现大约72%的成功企业家——72%，我希望你们记住这个数字——他们患有至少一种心理健康问题。其中许多人的抑郁症发病率实际上有所上升。你知道，我想，我不知道现在的数字是多少。我想是三分之一，或者可能，是的，三分之一的人在生活中会有某种心理健康问题。那大约是33%，而72%。72%真正身处这种追求成功、对成功痴迷的世界中的人，对此有着更强烈的感受。
And CEOs, the same study said that CEOs, some of the most successful people in the world, may be depressed at more than double the rate of the public at large. and here is my main point. And here is why I think we need to rethink this concept. Success is a very shallow thing to base your life meaning on. And when we are so focused on achieving some goal or having this external image of being the person that has it all, being disciplined, And often you miss out on doing things for the sake of just enjoying them or doing things,
首席执行官也是如此，同一项研究表明，首席执行官们——世界上最成功的一些人——抑郁的发病率可能是普通公众的两倍多。这就是我的主要观点。这也是为什么我认为我们需要重新思考这个概念。将你的人生意义建立在成功这样一个非常浅薄的基础之上是不对的。当我们如此专注于实现某个目标或拥有这种“拥有一切”的外部形象、保持自律时，
you know, pursuing a career, a life path because that's what you feel called towards, because that's what you actually care about. Here's the other aspect of this. And I know this is going to contradict a lot of what I've said, but, you know, most of the most successful people in the world are actually those who started out for themselves, who did it from a place of pure enjoyment. not for accolades, not for wealth, not for recognition, but because being good at something requires being committed to it
你往往会错过为了纯粹的享受而做的事情，或者错过做事情的机会，你知道的，去追求一个职业、一条生活道路，仅仅是因为你感到了内心的召唤，因为那是你真正关心的。这里还有另一个方面。我知道这会与我之前说过的很多话相矛盾，但是，你知道，世界上大多数最成功的人实际上是那些为自己而开始、出于纯粹的快乐去做这件事的人，
from a place of deep personal value, enjoyment, pleasure and care. And just actually feeling that even if no one else could see what you were doing, you would still be doing it. And here's why that's often the case and why I think that really undermines our initial perception of success. We think that the end goal is the thing that will motivate us all along. Actually, it's the process. And this first concept I want to talk about is called learned industriousness. And it refers to a phenomenon whereby people who are very successful who succeed in businesses, who succeed in sports, in music. They are the people who fell in love with the process and the act of
而不是为了荣誉、不是为了财富、不是为了认可，而是因为擅长某事需要出于对它深刻的个人价值、享受、乐趣和关怀而保持承诺。并且真正感觉到，即使没有其他人能看到你在做什么，你仍然会继续做下去。这就是为什么情况往往如此，以及为什么我认为这真正削弱了我们对成功的最初看法。我们认为最终目标是一路激励我们的东西。实际上，是这个过程。我想谈的第一个概念叫做“习得勤奋”（learned industriousness）。它指的是这样一种现象：那些非常成功的人——在商业、体育、音乐中取得成功的人——
doing rather than the outcome. This is backed up by another concept, another idea called flow. Now, we talk about the flow state a lot, but in case you haven't heard of it before, you haven't caught it in a past episode. Flow is basically a heightened state of consciousness when you're doing something that you equally love that equally challenges you, excites you, and it basically puts you in the zone and you feel fulfilled afterwards. your flow state is often what indicates your calling, right? Because you could sit there and do this thing for hours, not get bored, not get tired, feel fulfilled, feel not the opposite of exhausted, feel exhilarated. Now, flow is not the concept I'm talking about.
他们是那些爱上了过程以及“做”这一行为本身、而不是结果的人。这得到了另一个名为“心流”（flow）的概念的支持。现在，我们经常谈论“心流状态”，但如果你以前没听说过它，或者在过去的剧集里没听到过。心流基本上是一种高度的意识状态，当你做某件你同样热爱、同样挑战你、让你兴奋的事情时，它基本上让你进入了状态，事后你会感到充实。你的心流状态往往表明了你的天职，对吧？因为你可以坐在那里做这件事几个小时，不会感到无聊，不会感到疲倦，会感到充实，感受到的不是精疲力竭的反面，而是振奋。现在，心流并不是我要谈论的概念。
What I want to talk about is how they discovered flow. And if you listen to the TED Talk given back in 2008 by the creator of this concept, Professor Mihali Sinsa Mahali, he interviewed ballerinas, CEOs, chess players, elite cyclists, people who are incredibly, incredibly talented and good at what they do. And what he found was that the one thing they had in common was that, again, these people just really loved what they were doing and they weren't doing it for the acknowledgement. They weren't doing it for image, for publicity, for sponsors, for money. They were doing it because this is the thing that lit their fire.
我想谈的是他们是如何发现心流的。如果你听过这个概念的创造者米哈里·契克森米哈赖（Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi）教授在2008年做的TED演讲，他采访了芭蕾舞演员、首席执行官、国际象棋选手、精英自行车手，这些人在他们所做的事情上都极其非常有才华、非常优秀。他发现，他们唯一的共同点是，再次强调，这些人只是真的非常热爱他们正在做的事情，他们不是为了得到承认而做。他们不是为了形象、为了宣传、为了赞助商、为了金钱而做。他们这样做是因为这是点燃他们热情的火种。
True success comes down to feeling purposeful, feeling aligned with a mission, feeling aligned with a value of some sort, and genuinely just enjoying what you're doing, like actually sinking your teeth into life, into what you really love and what really, like, sets you a light and just doing it regardless of what other people are thinking. And I think that that is the huge switch that we need to make.
真正的成功归结为感到有目标感、与某种使命保持一致、与某种价值保持一致，并且真正地享受你正在做的事情，就像真正全身心地投入到生活中、投入到你真正热爱的事物中、投入到真正点燃你热情的事物中，并且不管别人怎么想都坚持去做。我认为这就是我们需要做出的巨大转变。
The huge understanding that we need to switch from thinking about success as something that is done for others and something that is praised by others, something that has an image to it. Instead, think about success as something that only you would care about, that only you truly know the meaning of and truly love. So I want to say this, you know, if you're feeling behind, if you don't feel like you're taking a life path that is expected of you or that you're not pursuing success in a traditional way,
我们需要做出重大理解转变，不再把成功视为为他人而做的事情、被他人称赞的事情、带有某种形象的事情。相反，把成功视为只有你自己才会关心、只有你自己真正知道其意义并真正热爱的事情。所以我想说的是，你知道的，如果你感到落后，如果你觉得你走的不是一条符合预期的人生道路，或者你没有以传统的方式追求成功，
if your dreams aren't going to make you famous, aren't going to give you headlines, aren't going to, you know, I don't know, aren't going to put you on like a public stage. you're probably actually doing what's right and you aren't missing out. In fact, I think you're closer to what true success looks like for most of us, which is actually joy and energy and love and just value and passion. I really want to talk about how we can actually find more of that and how we can truly be successful in our 20s with that more evolved understanding.
如果你的梦想不会让你成名、不会为你带来头条新闻、不会，你知道的，不会把你推上公众的舞台。你可能实际上正在做正确的事情，而且你并没有错过什么。事实上，我认为你更接近大多数人眼中真正成功的外在表现，那就是快乐、活力、爱以及纯粹的价值与激情。我真的想谈谈我们如何才能真正找到更多那样的东西，以及我们如何带着那种更成熟的理解在20多岁时真正取得成功。
So let's take a short break. Let me grab a glass of water. Let me catch my breath. And we'll be back shortly. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building
那么我们休息一会儿。我去喝杯水。喘口气。我们一会儿就回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在奇怪的现代世界中建立
resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and to work. way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越不切实际且运作方式的伪科学——这些伪科学充斥着整个健康产业。我们曾深信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
收听《2%》。即I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方上的T-W-O-Percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击丽尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟丽尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊可卡因，只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person
有时我们在追求某样东西时，会深陷于追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人很重要
while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
当你活在世上的时候？你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客中就疗愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。《Learn the Hard Way》。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来侦破此案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马蒂尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉
on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
面临欺诈指控。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。不作死就不会死。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》这一新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. If we stop focusing on being successful in our 20s
我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果我们停止关注20多岁时的成功
or elevating our reputation, looking good on LinkedIn, being traditionally accomplished, what would fill that space? What could we be focused on instead? I have a few suggestions. Instead of our 20s being about achieving that Wondikin status or being the best, I think instead our 20s could be focused on experimentation,
或者提升我们的声誉、在领英上光鲜亮丽、取得传统意义上的成就，什么能填补这个空白？我们还可以把重点放在什么上？我有一些建议。与其让我们的20多岁去追求那种“万金油”般的地位或力争第一，不如让我们的20多岁专注于尝试、
giving yourself three to four startovers to try new things and to really search for the thing that gives you meaning in life. Our 20s could also be for running towards the fear, taking things less seriously, celebrating our mistakes, what we're learning in the process. Like imagine if instead of, you know, putting promotions on your resume, you put on the times that you failed and you came back from it or what you learned. More than that, I think our 20s, should also be about having fun, and I know that is such a simplistic and shallow maybe for some of your way of saying things. But if this decade isn't about having fun, like what's it actually about? If it's not about making memories that guide yourself and guide you to who you really are,
给自己三到四次重新开始的机会去尝试新事物，并真正寻找赋予你生命意义的东西。我们的20多岁也可以用来迎难而上、放平心态、庆祝我们的错误以及我们在过程中学到的一切。想象一下，如果你的简历上写的不是获得晋升，而是你失败过几次、你是如何东山再起的，或者你学到了什么。不仅如此，我认为我们的20多岁，还应该充满乐趣，我知道对于你们中的某些人来说，这种说法可能过于简单和肤浅。但如果这个十年不是为了享受乐趣，那它到底是为什么呢？如果不是为了创造那些指引你自己、指引你成为真正自我的回忆，
when are you actually going to have time to do that with the level of self-awareness that you have now? Maybe this is my biggest problem with our current conception of what makes for an important and lucrative life, it makes everything so much less fun because you are constantly in a mindset of competition and comparison, needing to assess what others are doing and whether you are measuring up to that standard and often comparing yourself to the lives of people who we've already revealed may not actually be that happy, but because it looks that way from the outside, it feels like something that we want. As a result, I think that there is an overtone of serious, that settles over this time in our lives well before it should,
你什么时候才能真正有时间，带着你现在拥有的自我觉察水平去做这件事呢？也许这就是我对我们当前关于重要且多金的生活概念的最大不满，它让一切都变得索然无味，因为你总是处于竞争和比较的心态中，需要评估别人的做法以及你是否达到了那个标准，并且经常拿自己与那些我们已经发现其实并不那么快乐的人的生活进行比较，但因为从外表上看是那样的，它让人觉得是我们想要的。因此，我认为，在我们的生活步入这个阶段之前，一种严肃的基调就已经笼罩下来，
when actually we should be very uns seriousness, uns seriousness, unsurious in certain aspects and areas of our lives to make the most of this period of freedom, but to also set upon a self-discovery journey. What I really want for us is to kind of swap the isolation and the comparison and the flamboyance of traditional success for community, for self-knowledge, for discovery and for value.
而实际上我们在生活的某些方面和领域应该非常不严肃、不严肃、不严肃，以充分利用这段自由期，同时也开启一段自我发现之旅。我真正希望我们做的是，将传统成功的孤立、比较和浮华换成社群、自我认知、发现和价值。
To be truly successful in our 20s and to tap into that life source that we were talking about before, there are three things that I think we need to focus on instead of or in parallel to getting ahead in our careers and our finances, whatever. Firstly, is figuring out your sense of self and really finding your deep in a pool of authenticity to draw from. Secondly, is building strong relationships that you can rely on in the decades to come. and three is learning through experience and failure and being okay with not doing everything perfectly, but just doing it.
要在20多岁时取得真正的成功，并汲取我们之前讨论过的那股生命之源，我认为有三件事我们需要关注，它们可以替代或平行于在职业和财务等方面的领先。首先是弄清楚你的自我意识，并真正找到一个深深的真实自我之源来从中汲取养分。其次是建立牢固的人际关系，在未来几十年里你可以依靠它们。第三是通过经验和失败来学习，接受不把每件事都做到完美，而是只管去做。
When I see my friends who are really setting themselves up for an amazing bright future, for security and purpose, they all have those three things in common. They have a sense of who they are. They have a network and they have a flexible mindset that allows them to actually look at the world, see where they're needed, see what they want to do and pursue that. They are the people I think I feel most envious of, not because of the accolades or because they work 80 hours a week or they're disciplined, but because these individuals who I see in my own life just have this serene sense of mission and self-assurance that is incredibly admirable. And the, you know, the interesting thing is that they don't even care. They don't even care if I thought they were amazing because they feel it themselves and they feel drawn to something without the need for people.
当我看到我的朋友们真正为自己规划一个令人惊叹的光明未来、为了安全感和目标而努力时，他们都有这三个共同点。他们对我是谁有清醒的认识。他们拥有人脉，并且拥有灵活的心态，这使他们能够真正审视世界，看到自己的需求所在，看到自己想做的事并去追求。他们是我最嫉妒的人，不是因为荣誉，也不是因为他们一周工作80个小时或者很有纪律性，而是因为我在生活中看到的这些人，仅仅拥有这种令人难以置信的、令人钦佩的平静的使命感和自信。而且，你知道，有趣的是，他们甚至不在乎。他们甚至不在乎我是否觉得他们很棒，因为他们自己能感受到，并且被某种东西吸引，而不需要人们
public acknowledgement of it. So let's focus on how we can cultivate these things, the self-knowledge, the friendship, the openness to failure. Building self-knowledge means getting clear on where your internal compass is naturally leading you. There is a huge draw, I think, at the beginning of our 20s or the end of our teen years to big flashy careers like doctor, like lawyer, like entrepreneur, because they're impressive because you make a lot of money because they are traditionally, seen as people who have it together and who are, you know, going places in life. The further we get into this decade, though, and I'm not sure if I'm the only one who noticed this, but I noticed this shift around 21 and 22, people began to drop off from those career paths
公开承认这一点。所以让我们专注于如何培养这些品质：自我认知、友谊、对失败的开放态度。建立自我认知意味着弄清楚你的内在罗盘自然而然地引导你走向何方。我认为，在20多岁刚开始或青少年时期结束时，人们对医生、律师、企业家这样光鲜亮丽的大型职业有着巨大的吸引力，因为它们令人印象深刻，因为你能赚很多钱，因为它们传统上被视为那些生活井然有序、并且在生活中（你知道的）有所作为的人。然而，随着我们在这个十年里走得更远，我不确定我是唯一一个注意到这一点的人，但我注意到在21岁和22岁左右出现了这种转变，人们开始放弃那些职业道路，
because they begin to realize that their heart just isn't in those endeavors. They might be doing it for family because it's impressive or because they are squeezing into this box that their soul doesn't fit. and not to make it sound too spiritual, but that's how it feels. It feels uncomfortable to be pursuing a life that you actually don't even want more than, you know, you want it, but on a surface level. Getting to that realization quicker means getting clear on what actually inspires you, what you would do if no one was watching, not if money was no option.
因为他们开始意识到自己的心根本不在这些事情上。他们这样做可能是为了家庭，因为这样很有面子，或者因为他们把自己塞进了一个灵魂并不适合的盒子里。这听起来可能有点太灵性了，但感觉就是这样。追求一种你其实根本不想要的生活，比你表面上想要的还要让人感到不舒服。更快地认识到这一点意味着搞清楚究竟是什么在激励你，如果没人看着你会做什么，而不是如果金钱不是问题的话。
I know that's a question and often gets thrown out, but what would you do if no one was watching? if no one cared about what you were doing for better or for worse. And what do I genuinely derive joy from beyond my career and as a person? This is basically what we would call in therapy and psychology as a self-assessment exercise. I think we should all be doing it more periodically whereby we stop and we assess not just how we're tracking towards conventional traditional goals like financial goals, like financial goals or career goals, but how we're tracking towards the broader goal of being in touch with
我知道这是一个经常被抛出的问题，但如果没有人看着你会怎么做？如果没人关心你在做什么，无论是好是坏。除了我的职业之外，作为一个普通人，什么能真正让我感到快乐？这基本上就是我们在治疗和心理学中所说的自我评估练习。我认为我们都应该更定期地这样做，在此期间我们停下来评估，不仅是我们朝着传统目标（如财务目标或职业目标）前进的轨迹，还有我们朝着与
ourselves and our lives and how we feel. Obviously, I think self-knowledge in this decade can be difficult because we still are in a transition period. We are still developing as individuals and things do rapidly change. So that is why it's important to check in once every three months for 15 minutes such a small time investment, but to journal, ponder and think about these three questions. I think these three questions in particular really structure this self-investigation. What do I value the most in my life right now? What could I be doing to be more aligned with my purpose? And by purpose, we mean the thing that you would do when no one was watching, the thing that you care about beyond your career. And if you are anxious, dissatisfied, uncomfortable, what is the
自我、生活以及我们的感受保持联系这一更广泛目标的轨迹。很显然，我认为在这个十年里自我认知可能很困难，因为我们仍然处于过渡期。我们作为个体仍在成长，事情变化也很快。这就是为什么每三个月花15分钟进行一次签到很重要，这是一个很小的投资，但是去写日记、沉思并思考这三个问题。我认为这三个问题特别能构建这种自我探索。我目前生活中最看重什么？我可以通过做什么来更好地契合我的目标？所谓目标，指的是当没人看着时你会做的事，是你职业之外所关心的事情。如果你感到焦虑、不满意、不舒服，那么
source of this feeling and what needs to be amended? When you don't know yourself and you don't take time to care or to listen to your inner desires, perhaps because you are really caught up in being productive, in being efficient, in being successful. I really do think that you're setting yourself on the path for a huge crisis later on, and I've seen it time and time again in people's lives where they are very consumed by doing what they think needs to be done and following a traditional path. And there is never a space in that journey for self-reflection. And for really, thinking like what actually makes me happy. And so they wake up at 30, 35, 40, and they just feel even more lost than they would have at 20, 25 if they had sat and reflected. So focus on it now.
这种感觉的根源是什么，有什么需要修正的？当你完全不了解自己，也不花时间去关怀或倾听自己内心的渴望时，也许是因为你太执着于高产、高效和成功。我真的认为你是在为日后的一场巨大危机铺平道路，我在人们的生活中一次又一次地看到这种情况，他们非常沉迷于做他们认为必须做的事，并遵循传统的道路。而在那段旅程中，永远没有空间留给自我反思。也没有空间去真正思考到底什么才能让我快乐。所以当他们30岁、35岁、40岁醒来时，他们会感到比20岁或25岁时坐下来反思时更加迷茫。所以现在就去关注它吧。
I also think this is a unique time for risk. Some people get frustrated when I say this, but I do think that our 20s are the easiest time to do the things that might not get you further ahead in your career, but make sense for you as a person. And just kind of give you the chance to say in the future, yeah, I did that thing. That was part of my life story. Yeah, it was out of character. Yes, it may have not have contributed to me getting ahead in life, but I'm happy that I did it. The big one people often think of when I say that and when I say take risks, make memories in your 20s, is travel.
我也认为这是一个冒险的独特时期。有些人听到我这么说会感到沮丧，但我确实认为20多岁是做那些可能不会让你在职业生涯中走得更远，但对你作为一个人有意义的事情的最容易的时期。并且它给了你一个在未来能够说“是的，我做过那件事。那是我的生活故事的一部分。是的，这不符合我的性格。是的，它可能对我在生活中的晋升没有贡献，但我很高兴我做了”的机会。当我这么说，当我建议你在20多岁时去冒险、去创造回忆时，人们通常首先想到的就是旅行。
Of course, if you're tossing up between do I travel or settle into my corporate job and climb the ladder, my answer is always going to be travel if you have the opportunity. because that is going to set such a core foundation for future you who might choose to pursue a corporate life. It's not just travel. I think it's also things like going back to school for something that might not make you a success, but that you care about or taking a year to just make art or write and work whatever job pays the bills. This all gets us closer to understanding what we truly want. I think it also takes the pressure off having to come up with the answers to, what's going to make me successful, what's going to make me impressive, what do I want to do with
当然，如果你在纠结是去旅行还是稳定下来做你的公司职员、在职场爬格子，如果你有机会，我的答案永远是旅行。因为那将为未来的你奠定一个核心基础，而未来的你可能选择追求公司职员的生活。不仅仅是旅行。我认为它还包括诸如重返学校去学习一件可能不会让你成功、但你却很在乎的事情，或者花一年时间单纯地创作艺术、写作，做任何能付清账单的工作。这一切都让我们更接近理解我们真正想要的东西。我认为这也减轻了必须这么早得出以下答案的压力：什么能让我成功、什么能让我令人印象深刻、我想用我的
my life so early on. This is still a period of exploration, even if society is kind of putting, you know, kind of moving back the starting blocks a little bit and really putting a lot of pressure on the milestones. There is a wealth of experiences and knowledge to be collected in your 20s that are going to make you more successful in the long run. Secondly, friendships, our most prized relationships. If you feel like you have nothing to show for yourself in your 20s, that you're behind the people you went to high school with, or your colleagues or where you expected to be,
生活做什么。这仍然是一个探索的时期，即使社会在某种程度上有点把起跑线往后拉，并且给各个里程碑施加了很大的压力。20多岁时可以收集到丰富的经验和知识，从长远来看，这些将使你更加成功。其次，友谊，我们最宝贵的感情。如果你觉得自己在20多岁时一无所获，你落后于高中同学、同事或者你预期中的自己，
lean into your relationships and lean into your friendships. There is a quote that says, show me someone's friends and I'll tell you how rich they are. Not rich in wealth, but rich in connection, intimacy, vulnerability, having those kindred spirits to ride through life with. There are so many people who have a narrow goal and an even narrower focus on how to get there because they do think it would give their life more meaning to be the big success story. But we know from earlier discussions that once they get to that finish line,
那就依靠你的人际关系，依靠你的友谊。有一句名言说，展示某人的朋友，我就会告诉你他们有多富有。不是财富上的富有，而是连接、亲密、脆弱性上的富有，拥有那些能与你共度人生的志同道合的灵魂。有许多人有着狭隘的目标，对于如何到达那里有着更狭隘的焦点，因为他们认为成为一个伟大的成功故事会赋予他们生活更多的意义。但我们从先前的讨论中知道，一旦他们到达了那个终点线，
often one of their first thoughts is, who do I share this with? There is no success without community. the relationships that you are devoting yourself to now are the things that will also make you successful in your future. And so there's another element of this that I want to talk about. You can really only grow as far as your friendships allow you to. So yeah, if you are someone who wants big things, if you are someone who wants a creative life, who wants an adventurous life, actually be particular about who you're surrounding yourselves with. Because I do sometimes think that as much as we want companionship and connection, you don't want to be limited by someone else's
他们的第一想法往往是：我和谁分享这个？没有社群就没有成功。你现在全身心投入的人际关系，也是未来会让你成功的事物。所以这里还有我要谈的另一个要素。你的友谊能让你成长到什么地步，你就能成长到什么地步。所以，是的，如果你是一个渴望宏大事物的人，如果你是一个渴望创造性生活、渴望冒险生活的人，那么在选择周围陪伴的人时要挑剔。因为我确实有时认为，尽管我们渴望陪伴和联系，但你可不想被别人对他们生活的期望所产生的
beliefs about what they want from their life. Hopefully that's making sense, but I think be selective and put time and energy and effort into your friendships and see that as something that is a mark of success. See that as something that you can say, yeah, I am full of wealth as a person. I have achievement. I am impressive. I have accolades because my relationships are fulfilling and deep and vulnerable and rich. Finally, something else that makes you successful in your 20s is an openness to failure and being able to adapt and go lightly through life. That is what's going to make this a pivotal period for you.
信念所限制。希望这说得通，但我认为要有选择性，把时间和精力投入到你的友谊中，并将其视为成功的标志。将其视为你可以说的事情：“是的，作为一个普通人我财富满满。我有成就。我很令人印象深刻。我有荣誉，因为我的关系是充实、深厚、脆弱且丰富的。”最后，能让你在20多岁时成功的另一件事是对失败的开放态度，并且能够适应生活、轻松前行。这才是让这段时期成为你转折点的关键。
Each setback teaches resilience and I think adapting from that builds confidence. There is no one in life who is going to walk through any period, any chapter, any month even, without experiencing something that just like doesn't sit right, that's inconvenient to them, that makes them feel insecure, that makes them feel like a failure. The people who get over that faster and who are able to keep pursuing their deep inner calling or the thing they care about are the people who are adaptable and flexible and who allow room for that in their journey. I think that's very hard to do, when you're really focused on perfection and you're really focused on making a name for yourself
每一次挫折都教会我们韧性，我认为从挫折中适应能建立自信。生活中没有人能在任何时期、任何章节、甚至任何一个月里走过来，而不经历一些感觉不对劲、对自己很不方便、让自己感到不安全、让自己觉得自己像个失败者的事情。那些能更快从阴影中走出来、并能继续追求自己内心深处的召唤或所关心事物的人，是那些适应力强、灵活并且在人生旅程中为这些留出空间的人。我认为这很难做到，当你过度专注于完美、过度专注于为自己扬名立万
and doing it right the first time and you're really focused on how other people perceive your journey and how other people are perceiving your successes take a step back from that for a second this is not their life this is not their journey you are the one who is experiencing your day to day and I, you know, I saw this amazing quote that the people in life who are truly the most successful, who have the best businesses, who inspire people, who make change, they always have the most interesting stories about how they got there because they didn't stick strictly to a path. They put themselves on an 18 or 20 and they didn't expect for everything to go right. They bounced back from failure.
并且第一次就把它做好，并且你过度专注于别人如何看待你的旅程、别人如何看待你的成功时，退后一步，这不是他们的生活，这不是他们的旅程，你才是那个体验日常生活的人，而且，你知道，我看到过这样一句精彩的名言：生活中真正最成功、拥有最好的企业、激励人们、带来改变的人，他们总是拥有关于如何走到那里的最有趣的故事，因为他们并没有死守一条道路。他们在18或20岁时将自己投入其中，并没有指望一切都一帆风顺。他们从失败中恢复过来。
They accepted it. They made it part of who they were becoming. So just a really good reminder. And I want to just finish this up, close off this episode by saying, firstly, thank you for listening to me Ramble. Obviously, this is something that has been on my mind. I'm trying to rethink and evolve my own understanding of success in this moment alongside you.
他们接受了失败。他们把它变成了他们自我成长的一部分。所以这真的是一个很好的提醒。我想通过这样的话来结束、为这一集画上句号：首先，感谢你听我唠叨。很显然，这是一直在我脑海里盘旋的想法。我正试图在此时此刻与你们一起重新思考和演变我对成功的理解。
So if you do have any thoughts, feelings about this yourself, please let me know. But secondly, I really do think that it's time to get rid of this confined, outdated model of what a successful individual looks like. It is not someone who I think is materialistic or who is outwardly the most beautiful, most impressive, has the most things to their name. It's the person who you look at and you say, no, that is someone who has a really deep pool of inner peace and cares about something and they draw from that in any aspect of their life. And it doesn't have to be their job, right? It could be someone who is like literally working at McDonald's but really cares about their athletics career or really cares about making ceramics on the weekend. That is someone who knows
所以如果你自己对此有任何想法、感受，请告诉我。但其次，我真的认为现在是时候抛弃这种狭隘、过时的成功人士模式了。成功人士不是我认为的那种物质至上的人，或者在表面上最美丽、最令人印象深刻、名下拥有最多东西的人。而是那个你看一眼就会说：“不，那是一个内心深处有着真正平静、并且真正在乎某件事的人，他们在生活的任何方面都能从中汲取力量。”而且这不一定非得是他们的工作，对吧？它可能是一个 literalmente 在麦当劳工作但在乎自己的田径生涯或在周末热心制作陶艺的人。那是一个了解
themselves. That is someone who hopefully has a community around them. That is someone who is open to failure. Those are true markers of success. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. I hope it's given you something to think about or that you've learned something from the studies we talked about, from the random quotes we threw in there, from my rambling. If you enjoyed this episode, if you feel like there is someone else in your life who needs to hear it, please. feel free to share it with them. And make sure you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, and follow along for more episodes.
自己的人。那是一个身边希望有社群的人。那是一个对失败持开放态度的人。这些才是成功的真正标志。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。希望它能给你带来一些启示，或者让你从我们讨论的研究、我们引用的随机名言、我的唠叨中学到一些东西。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你觉得你生活中还有其他人需要听听这个，请随意与他们分享。并且一定要在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，并关注以获取更多节目。
I'll give you guys some sneak peek on what's coming up. Next week we're going to be talking about female friendship. We're going to be talking about people who are overly sensitive and sibling relationships and a lot more. So lots to be excited about. Hopefully we see you back here very soon. And until next time, Stay safe. Stay kind. Be gentle with yourself. Rethink your notions of success. And we will talk soon.
我给你们剧透一下接下来会发生什么。下周我们将讨论女性友谊、过度敏感的人、兄弟姐妹关系以及更多内容。所以有很多令人兴奋的事情。希望我们很快在这里再次见到大家。在下次再见之前，保持安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。重新思考你的成功观念。我们很快会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier war fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、健身以及在奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方上的TWO%。在《Look Back at It》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild.
从1979年开始，这对我和说是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何熬过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的。
I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
我的意思是，这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全、但你却能和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的坦诚对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHard radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们决定自己
own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
动手。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这么逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。